good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast live and
in studio we're back happy
monday everyone hope everyone had an
amazing and fulfilling weekend did you
have a fulfilling weekend
you know what i think i had a very
fulfilling weekend because
i fulfilled myself for sure
that's so important it's the first step
in fulfillment
but day three and four were saturday and
sunday of my cleanse and i stuck to my
cleanse all weekend
like i said on friday i am on day five
today guys we are on track
to make it all the way and my whole life
right now just revolves around this
cleanse but i've gotten so much support
from the toasters oh not for me no i
mean i haven't got really every time i
pick up the phone i say you're glowing
the whites of your eyes are blinding
that's literally not what she says i did
say you i didn't say
yeah i did my makeup a little
differently because i'm just like tired
of using so much powder 100 but isn't
that funny how like you make a small
change on your face and you think people
on the street are gonna like stop you
and notice no but i i just thought maybe
you would stop me and notice like
because i'm on day five
of my clients no um but it's definitely
like an inner glow
thank you well i've just gotten so much
support and so many people telling me
that they want me to talk about it
please and just hear updates so so far
it's really good i think it's a very
doable cleanse like you really need to
prepare yourself mentally and also like
you need to prepare your kitchen and
have
all the ingredients that are needed um
so it's a big endeavor
but going day to day like it's not
impossible
and with every day that passes like i
just feel more encouraged to make it to
the end
so what are you going to eat like on
your first well
okay so first i just want to say like
now having done this cleanse it's given
me a whole new appreciation for
smoothies
and now i'll be making smoothies in the
home like with good ingredients you know
with a little almond milk
that will be delicious sure so i'm
excited for that but they do say that
you should like
wean off of the cleanse so like do a
smoothie in the morning whatever you
want and then like a meal for dinner so
like half like
so that you don't startle your body yeah
so what my meal will be i guess i'll be
done on sunday night dinner
we still have a whole other week yeah
it's ten days i'm on day five
my last day is saturday i know i know
geez
but my name you guys really want the
whites of your eyes to be well also i'm
losing weight
so like that's motivating like that's if
i like i've been wearing myself i've
lost three pounds so far which is really
exciting but um just keep in mind that i
gained five pounds on vacation
so we've got two more to go before the
deficit before we're back at the start
well i am just like the peak of health i
don't even need to do
cleanses and i'm a medical marvel yet
again yet again but also this is my
first time ever doing the toast
in studio without a coffee like i can't
drink coffee
that's crazy by now i've i've weaned off
of it so it's not like i'm craving it
but i do feel a little like out of focus
yeah you know well that's like yom
kippur like when you can't have coffee
like you have a headache
yeah well i get a headache on young
people just from being hungry and do you
have ykb on this juice cleanse
no i feel like my breath is like better
than ever i feel like
the natural ingredients like are doing
wonders for my breath by the way
i think that that's true like i believe
that you look like your t
your mouth like looks clean thanks
claudia
well we have a great show for you guys
today just a full monday full of stuff
we have a real housewives of atlanta tv
recap
um i'll talk a little bit about uh about
rupaul's drag race
which um i'm very excited about and i
honestly like i really need you to get
into it like
it's so much work but i have to tell you
i watched it i watched pretty much
all the seasons the ones that matter
during quarantine and i haven't watched
like a single episode since
and on friday i watched the premiere
episode
and when the when the theme song came on
rupaul's drag race
may the best woman best woman win
i kid you not i was transported to the
darkest time like
i watched it in like march april and
that was just like a hard time for the
country for the world
and when that song came on i swear like
i wanted to turn the tv off but i won't
let quarantine like ruin rupaul's dragon
again
so i persevered but i'm telling you
every time i hear that song now i get a
little chill down my spine like
it's i just i got a flashback remember
when i knitted that blanket for michaela
during quarantine that she is like
obsessed with yeah um i needed that
blanket while i was watching rupaul's
drag race and i
literally like in my bed when i heard
the song i started like knitting like
it was crazy like muscle memory and it
was really upsetting because it's like
rupaul's drag race is something like
it's a special like when i watch it it's
a treat
and i won't have it be ruined by march i
just will not let march ruin it
i feel like you can undo the
previous connotations i'm so motivated
to do so
that rupaul's drag race will not be
ruined for me it just won't a lot of
things have been ruined for me
tie dye ruined so many things one tree
hill
ruined yeah well that was my fault but
yeah you know what i mean
it's just been like 2020 was a year of
ruining things for sure
i would take on rupaul's drag race my
content plate is just so full and now
i'm feeling like even some of the things
that i
watch that i used to enjoy like i don't
anymore i'm watching season two of
virgin river and i don't know if it's
not good or it's me but like
i literally can get through half an
episode a night but also i'm liking
watching it as i go to sleep because
it's so scenic and beautiful yes
it's as if you're just like watching
scenic scenes did you finish bridgerton
i did and we have a story about raider
tin and we'll recap it today okay great
so atlanta housewives and bridgerton in
the tv recap segment i cannot wait to
hear your thoughts
um then one more thing i just don't
really want to formally put it in the tv
recap is my journey watching lost
me and ben over the weekend probably
watched like 20 episodes like we really
made it
well into the fourth season and it's
it's good it's like a show that has like
peaks and valleys you know it's like
highs and lows
but it's just like frustrating because
whole premise of the show is like
they're on the island and like
just get off like it's so frustrating
and all these like rescue missions it's
like it's only season four i know you're
not getting off the island you know
yeah so it's it's actually like a really
frustrating show okay
well i feel like you should finish it
because i'm pretty sure like this
the end is very crazy um so i like
i don't want to say because i think i
remember like in high school everyone
talking about it and like i feel like i
know what the ending what do you think
it is
i don't want to say because i don't want
people like messaging me like i just
i just have a but i also make things up
so like it really could be
those have a bad memory right but i have
this like vision of like my friend jason
who was like obsessed with the show like
talking about it and like i overheard
i'm like i'm never gonna watch his show
and like i think i remember what he said
but i also think tv critics like regard
it as a bad ending
do they i think well i mean it's
subjective because i think tv critics
also regard game of thrones as a bad
ending
and i really liked it i didn't really
like it but i appreciated the
continuity and like how the ending made
sense they didn't just slap like dan as
gossip girl you know like that made no
[ __ ] sense
logistically like you could go through
the show and see when like gossip girl
sent out an alert and dan was like at a
party like
and he like literally roasted himself
his family like he did
jenny his sister so dirty makes no sense
logistically like dan being gossip girl
makes no logical sense bran spoiler
alert if you never watch game of thrones
here's your turn to turn it off
bran becoming king of the north it's
like the only scenario that actually
made sense
the king of the world yeah the realm of
westeros
um also totally like random but what are
your thoughts on
like spoiling tv shows that aired 10
years ago i feel really good about it
yeah me too
because i'm keeping this meme going
around like you could still spoil tv
show
no sorry you missed the boat like no and
even if we
unless you're you happen to be watching
game of thrones right now like i'm so
sorry i didn't even
consider that but if you're going to
watch game of thrones in the future like
you will not remember what we just said
because what we said right now like
doesn't make any sense to you
no but bran is the king of westeros game
of thrones ended
two years ago all right you know what
i'll give people time to watch it
but like saying i spoiled um
[Music]
lost which literally went off the air 10
years ago
that's a you problem not a me problem
maybe we should include a spoiler alert
in the description
just because i i do feel bad about the
game of thrones one like yeah that show
is so long like there's so much
build up like i mean that's the payoff i
gave a spoiler alert when i spoke no no
i'm gonna just put in the description in
the episode description whatever time
we're at
like game of thrones spoiler if you
happen to be watching um
so that's our that's our mini tv recap
but the big one's coming later you don't
want to miss it the big one's coming
later you don't want to miss it but
before we get to that we
must deliver wait before you deliver
before you deliver the pizza before i
stand and deliver before you stand and
deliver
we have to talk about the fact that we
are now two weeks away from my book
launch
sorry it's happening you guys two weeks
a week does it launch tuesday so two
weeks from tomorrow okay
um and i don't know maybe you would be
able to answer this question as my
little my most literary friend
when a book comes out like a song comes
out on friday
at midnight so like thursday night yeah
just like the kindle book come out at
midnight on monday
oh that's a good question for kindles
because i figured like bookstores it
comes out when it opens amazon it's like
when your book even if you pre-order it
it'll come up on the day that it comes
out but like whenever your mail gets
delivered that's interesting for kindles
i feel like we're about to find out yeah
i'm just curious because again i'm a
first-time author
of my book girl with no job the crazy
beautiful life of an instagram thirst
monster
this is a hardcover copy which comes
with a photo insert which is very
exciting i'm not going to spoil it for
you if you're watching on youtube
but the book is just a really personal
piece of work that i've been really
looking forward to putting out because i
have
i have some things to say and you know
what i said them in this book you can
get it at girlsnowjob.com
book it comes out in two weeks i would
really appreciate the pre-order support
because i'm trying to get into all types
of book stores and if i have strong
pre-order numbers i can get to the front
of the bookstore instead of being like
shoved in the back where no one can see
me
so again girl with no job the crazy
beautiful life of an instagram thirst
monster audiobook
ebook and hardcover are all available
for pre-order at various outlets
um you can shop big you can shop small
book thank you all so much for the
support like the pre-order numbers are
in and they're very strong and
everyone's very happy with it and i'm
very happy with it
so i just love you guys so much thanks
for putting up with me these last two
months we only got two more weeks so
it's gonna be fun
damn what are we gonna talk about when
it's over um know maybe we have to
rev up for a new secret project or maybe
we could just like revel in like you
know
the the success all the critics saying
it's the best book i've
ever read making reese's list i don't
know these are just things that i think
might happen but you know what list it
is going to make
the redheads list because we are doing
an episode with claudia and speaking of
the redheads our new episode dropped
today we're recapping layla by colleen
hoover which is just a super popular
book she's a very popular author
and all of the redheads at the end of
the day likes the books so
i think that if you read it you will
like it too and even if you don't want
to read it
the episode is hysterical oh good and
you should listen to it anyway and also
all of us read so many books over the
holidays so we are recapping all of them
and letting you know like which ones we
recommend
which ones we don't dana even had a dnr
a do not read
wow did she finish it no what book i
forget
dana suggested a dnr to me what was it
um
how to murder your life i'm not gonna
lie i actually really liked it in the
beginning and then it was just like
repetition after repetition after
repetition like she works at a magazine
she's addicted to pills
she [ __ ] something up can we what
happens next like yeah it was just so
repetitive
um but i actually think i might finish
it i think that you should
i just think like you're an impatient
person and sometimes books lag and you
don't have the time for that
okay i just want to say i am an
impatient person but
i withstand with books like honestly the
worst book i ever read that i can't
believe is so [ __ ] world-renowned
daisy jones in the six
yeah i said it terrible [ __ ] book um
was the most boring book i've ever read
in my life i
i don't know do other people get angry
when they read books that are like not
fulfilling them
yes like i wanted to kick and scream
like i was so angry
um but i still persevered even that one
you gave me the unfortunate importance
of beauty which ended up being
so stupid i still finish it well i like
skim less you're hurting people's
feelings now
i'm just giving my opinion you're
hurting feelings that's how high my bar
is because that's how good
my book is true
true now you can stand and deliver now i
can stand and deliver the fast five
stories that you need to know before you
wake up and take a bite out of your
morning toast
and excuse me it's rdh it's coming
back can i get you something
do you need your ads i've been watching
so many people die on lost spoiler
alert um and i'm really getting into
like this is how you die like
you have to like pause and then take one
final breath
um but the rdh didn't get me today
because i got my ad copy today we have a
brand new sponsor actually not new
because they
just been a while they took a little
break but fashion pass is absolutely
everything of the sort it's a clothing
rental service that we uh
love here at the morning toast jackie
and mark have been using them forever
that's how i found out about it
and it's really like a it's like a rent
the runway meets revolve like fabulous
clothing
that you can borrow hold on to wear and
then return and get some new stuff
so people think that you just have like
a never-ending wardrobe right and
sometimes especially with like instagram
culture you wear something one said
photographer you take a picture and then
you can't wear it for a while so with
fashion pass you just have like the
rotating closet
i've been using fashion pass since last
year i think it's like a brilliant
brilliant idea and like a perfectly
executed company
they have the cutest stuff i just got
the cutest um oprah ski
sweater cute and um this really cute
coat that i would never
buy on my own but like now that i'm just
experimenting like yeah i'm wearing this
coat
they have great brands like for love and
lemons free people show me your moomoo
it's like the revolve of rental services
if you hate spending 200 on one sweater
dress jacket
that you might only wear once then
fashion pass might be for you and if
you're a trendsetter like me
it's like you got to keep up with the
trends and that can be expensive that's
why it's really smart
for us trendsetters to uh head over to
fashion pass
um one of the best parts is that if you
love something and you want to end up
keeping it you get a huge discount
anywhere between 30 and 60
off which is fabulous um it's a better
option than constantly shopping and it's
more sustainable and better for the
environment
and we actually have a special discount
code for you today it is the best deal
that fashion pass has
ever offered if you go to the
fashionpass.com
use code toast at checkout you'll get 50
off your first month so you can try it
for just 29
that's the fashionpass.com code toast at
checkout
you get 50 off your first month so you
can try it for 29
check it out we love the fashion pass
here and it is toast approved so
yeah it's everything of the sort and
it's like the exact company you've been
looking for
yeah okay are you ready to get into the
stories yes ma'am the first one is some
big news of the day
um and i'm worried my reaction is going
to disappoint everyone
i couldn't help but wonder do i care
about this
you're gonna sex and the city revival is
confirmed at hbo max
the new chapter is titled and just like
that and will star sarah jessica parker
cynthia nixon and kristen
davis kim cattrall who played samantha
jones is not returning
parker nixon and davis will also
executive produce along with michael
patrick king
the revival will follow carrie charlotte
and miranda as they navigate love and
friendship in their 50s
the series will consist of 10 half-hour
episodes and is set to begin production
in new york city in late spring
so here's the thing i am a big fan
of sex in the city i actually talk about
this a lot in my book um not to keep
plugging it
but just how you know you watch
something growing up and like the way
you feel about it changes over time
that's just natural as you grow up
and you know for me like i've grown up
and realized like how toxic
carrie is but the show had other great
elements
that kind of sustained the toxicity like
samantha like she was absolutely
everything of this sort like a modern
woman an independent woman
and she like you know made some of the
more
unbearable scenes bearable and now that
we don't have what i thought was like
really
samantha was the straw that stirs the
drink i just i can't imagine that this
is going to be very good and i'm the
type of person where it's like i
actually loved both movies even though
they were like so stupid like
i would watch the four of them like i
really would watch them anywhere i would
watch this revival this is not like a
reboot like that nobody needs like i
would watch it honestly
and they're great it really is a reboot
like it's this main character
it's not like sex in the city again
where it's like a young generation i
thought maybe that's what it would be
but that's actually kind of interesting
yeah
it's interesting but they always ruin it
that way so like to bring back the
actual original cast and just continue
the show is a great idea but i agree
like samantha is a
big major piece of the puzzle and
without her
i just i fear for the quality for the
success and you know what else is crazy
like if you think about it
like which one of them could the show
survive without honestly i don't know i
don't think i would watch it without
charlotte i don't think a lot of people
would
i wouldn't watch it without miranda like
i'm a miranda stan
and also i read about in my book how
like she deserves justice and there's a
whole theory on it
but i actually think i could watch the
show without the protagonist
carrie yeah a hundred percent yeah i
don't know even though the women like
aren't as close
as a group without carrie is the
glue that holds yes exactly and i don't
think it makes any sense without carrie
and nobody's
offering that so annoying i just wish
that they worked a little harder to get
kim catrell like whatever her needs were
and maybe they all could have like
you know talked it out wait i don't
think it was a needs thing i think it
was like
a personality like kim patrell has been
like very vocal about like her distaste
for sarah jessica parker yeah but like i
don't know nothing a little couple
cosmos can't fix like okay i just feel
like they
could work it out you know yeah i just
feel like people don't try hard enough
to work it out i think
that's definitely true because kim
cattrell has no interest in working out
like whatever she's upset about
that happened years ago and then in the
movies like this
the wound is real and she like is not
interested in and i think she's
financially very fine from her stint on
the show
and i just don't think she wants to put
herself back and that's a part of
growing up like not putting yourself in
toxic environment
it's so true but then it's like do you
agree with their decision to go ahead
with a reboot without her no
me neither but then but it's like we're
in the age of reboots hbo max is a
streaming service now we're just making
[ __ ] all the time the other three women
are down
let's do it yeah i just would have liked
for like the legacy of sex in the city
to be preserved like ending in abu dhabi
which was honestly
i loved that movie sometimes i like it
better than the first one like i think
it was so
funny and there's so many like lines
that like truly make me like laugh
out loud and i could have ended the
story there like i think it was a
storybook ending there was supposed to
be a third movie
kim catra backed out and the whole movie
fell apart um and now this is like
them picking up the pieces i don't know
sometimes it's like it's best to leave
things
you know where they were i agree with
that
but we'll see what they do we'll see
what they do i'll watch
i love some of the i love charlotte and
i love miranda i love the ladies
yeah i love samantha though like she's
just so funny
she's so funny and you grow up and i
feel like sorry we're gonna say
something did i cut you off no i was
just gonna say like she's
number one number one and like i feel
like when you grow up you're like smith
is crazy and then like you get older and
you're like
oh my god she's right about everything
yeah everything from business to
relationships
and i'm just not interested in watching
a show without the woman who's right
about everything
i completely agree so i'm so glad we're
on the same page so they're gonna need
to find a way to balance it maybe
they'll bring in a different fourth cast
member who has
like something to bring to the table in
terms of personality or like a
uh someone who was on the fringe who
like has more
more to offer like stanley or something
yeah i didn't love stanley
honestly i liked um stanley's husband
yeah
what was his name sanford oh his name is
not stanley
sorry stamford that's how important he
was he married charlotte's gay best
friend
anthony anthony anthony was everything
of the sort yeah but they can't make one
of
them the fourth i think they'll bring in
a fourth i do ride were a dress
by no one he's everything yeah
so we'll keep you posted it's going to
be a while before we see it because
they're not even filming till the spring
and
you know how things go yeah and maybe
this will suffer the same fate as the
doomed hillary duff reboot i mean lizzie
mcguire reboot oh
true you know now it's just because
something gets greenlit lizzie maguire
has really
haunted us doesn't mean it's happening
you guys i wouldn't get too excited that
is so true
because everyone was all jazzed about
lizzie mcguire
okay next up some more tv news the
kardashians commemorate last day of
filming keeping up with the kardashians
ahead of the final
season trying not to get emotional
keeping up with the kardashians wrapped
filming on its final episode friday and
the kardashian jenner family
commemorated the occasion on social
media with a series of emotional
posts introducing the show's audio tech
of 14 years erin paxton kim noted that
this is our last keeping up
miking of life she panned over to show
all of the mics and then another clip
shows the casts place settings for lunch
which um
had cookies designed with their faces on
them from funny face bakery which is the
same bakery that did my birthday cookies
yes i
recognized their work they did such a
good job on
kardashian cookies um i want to say two
things about this one i just occurred to
me as you were reading this very sad
story that theo sat with you today
so my heart is just heavy with all this
news coming at me um and the other thing
is like it was really crazy like
i know we're gonna get more kardashian
content in the future and this is by no
means the end of like a family reality
show for the kardashians
um and we know that because of their big
hulu deal but it definitely
this is huge it signifies the end of an
era yeah
it really does and it must be sad for
them like of course they're
moving on to bigger and better things
but like they've worked with these
people for so long
and they're gonna have new crews and new
mic packs and all this new stuff and
it's
it's the end of an era i was watching
everyone's content and kylie like
obviously showed up in a look
and i just like wasn't feeling the
emotion from kylie cause like now she
was like last day of filming i was like
when was first day yeah no like you
never started like you still have
orientation
she just like her posts were just like
posted to be posted but like i wasn't
feeling the raw emotion like i was from
like
courtney and kim the people who really
grew up on the show
i totally agree yeah she just like
showed up in the look like two pictures
she like loved the cookies
but like there was no real connection i
think i i do feel i thought the same
thing
it just lacked a certain emotion yeah
like for kim like it's just crazy
no for kim it's like look what she
really her and chris look what they did
with
this little shitty tv show i know a
million families who have gotten reality
shows 100
and did absolutely nothing with them and
now like just
they blazed a trail i can't even you
can't even put into words like what that
show did for society like you know what
i mean
for the television industry the
entertainment industry for women in
business
for beauty like and look what they did
like with this like little 30-minute
show
yeah in their little ranch in calabasas
yeah
crazy really crazy i also think it's
crazy like the fact that they don't own
that house like that original house the
fact that they
never kept it in their real estate
portfolio i'm sure when they sold it
they like they weren't at a place where
they were just like owning houses for
purposes and now someone else owns it
maybe when it goes up for sale they'll
buy it hundred percent
yeah hun where's that okay ready for our
next story cause hearts are gonna be
breaking
all over the world michael b jordan is
off the market
okay he's gone instagram official with
lori harvey after months of romance
rumors
so as much as hearts are breaking i
think this is like
perhaps one of the best couples like in
terms of like they're so eligible for
each other like i actually think this is
such a good pairing
yeah that i'm okay with um hearts being
broken i think it's worthwhile
okay well on sunday people's reigning
sexiest man alive never forget how
sexy he is appeared to debut his romance
with lori harvey on instagram sharing a
photo of the pair for the first time
he posted two portraits of him and
harvey including one photo of them
smiling
at one another in close embrace the
actor and daughter of steve harvey were
previously photographed together
during the holiday season i think this
is such a good couple like i'm so happy
for them
wow that is just like such an exciting
like i don't want to you know
jinx it i don't want to jump ahead but
like have michael b jordan to be
steve harvey's son-in-law no the power
is
just math sexiness the sexiness steve
harvey has like really become a figure
in my home i've been watching family
feud like almost every night before bed
and what a character that guy is and
imagine like going home for dinner and
having dinner with steve harvey
no i'm sure it's hysterical hysterical
actually you know i got my start on the
steve harvey show you could read about
it in my book so
true january 26 2021 is when it comes
out tell the story about how steve you
know
he had a lot of faith in me he did he
did he really did
he he just knew that i had it yeah you
should read about that
you should it's good stuff i'm happy for
them obviously i'm sad for the millions
of women who were just like
broken inside but um but
i'm heading down to the port getting my
i'll meet you i'm getting my hammer
i'm making a sailor's knot and i'm
getting on the boat
i'm building a big ship for these two
noah's ark some would say
totally um is the fourth story the one
that's brought to you
by frame bridge by chance i don't know
what are the odds yes
it is which is so crazy that's weird
it's crazy
wait can we just talk about like how
crazy that is what are the odds
insanity well i guess i better tell you
guys that today's episode is brought to
you by frame bridge
they make it easier and more affordable
than ever to frame your things without
ever leaving the house
add a gallery wall to your home office
or send the perfect gift from art prints
and diplomas to photos sitting on your
phone
you can frame bridge just about anything
here's how it works
go to framebridge.com and upload your
photo straight from your phone
or they can send you a package to safely
mail in a physical photo
you can preview your item online and
does in the frame in dozens of frame
styles and gallery wall layouts
you choose your favorites or you can get
free recommendations from their talented
designers
the experts at frame bridge will custom
frame your item and deliver your
finished piece directly to your door
ready to hang instead of hundreds you'd
pay at a framing store
their prices start at 39 and all
shipping is free plus our listeners can
get a 15
off discount at your first order at
framebridge.com when you use the promo
code toast
so if you want to get started today
frame your photos or send someone the
perfect gif i know jackie has a big ass
picture of herself
framed in her living room so if that's
your aesthetic framebridge can help you
whatever your aesthetic frame we're just
here to help
go to framebridge.com and use the promo
code toast to save an additional 15
off your first order just go to
framebridge.com promo code toast again
that's
frame bridge.com promo code toast
i can't believe you just happened to
pick the fourth story that was brought
to you by frame bridge that's like a
crazy coincidence it's a crazy
coincidence we're like on the same
level yeah um okay so our fourth story
you're not gonna care about okay but i
think people will and i did i was
surprised to see it love island steli
vasquez and johnny middlebrooks have
split
steli and johnny jelly she said she's so
thankful for their time together
so did they win no they did not win and
i'm
justine and caleb i haven't seen them
post together in a while but i haven't
seen that they've broken up so like
no news is good news i'm staying on my
ship but
sally and johnny have broken up she said
because you've all been such a close
part of our relationship i wanted to
share with you
that johnny and i are no longer together
while our relationship has been public
from the start i do ask that you respect
this decision and our privacy during
this time
there's no reason to speculate i'm so
thankful for our time together but now
it's simply time for each of us to focus
on our personal journey
so okay i mean i think a lot of people
like always you didn't watch the season
but like it got a little crazy
between the two of them because like
they brought in all these other girls
and the girls and the guys split and
they went to like
some more it's the stupidest thing
and when johnny johnny and sally were
like oh they were the power couple in
the house and they split up boys and
girls boys went to casa and more
they brought in all these girls and
johnny just like went ham with this
other girl okay
and then came back no no and then
came back and like didn't tell sally and
then like um
people sometimes there would be like
tweets that would be part of the episode
like they would read america's tweets
about them it's like america was like
trying to tell sally what happened right
and every time they brought in a new
person she's like did you see the scene
like what happened
so everyone like gave them a really hard
time about being a couple but they
seemed really happy together
um so this is like sad love island news
but
you know things happen i still think
it's crazy and probably like
i'm actually shocked i don't watch but
my content plate is just so full
um i just think it's crazy how they film
love island in real time and i think
it's like so cool
yeah and i think like more reality shows
should do that yeah they do a really
really good job it is
so much for a content play because it's
every night of the week right but
what does it play for like three weeks
yeah i guess three or four weeks
it's a nice reprieve and also it came at
a time when there wasn't housewives on
every single night so
every night the housewives honestly andy
and his programming team
have no respect for my slumber yeah it's
very upsetting
okay our next story more tv news this is
just like all tv stuff but bridgerton
has been tipped to run for eight seasons
not confirmed just the creation the
creator said that he is down
and wants to do bridgerton for eight
seasons
because the book has eight books
got it and i actually learned a lot from
this article because when i watched the
show which i loved my only thing was
like i wonder why it's called bridgerton
because it's like that's the name of a
family it should have been the name of
the town and what the hell is the name
of the town
the name of the town i don't know i
watch with
uh subjects and i'm so glad that i do
otherwise i would keep thinking they're
saying talk of the town but they're
saying talk of the ton
also i love that i love watching the
subtitles because then i realize that
every song they're playing
is actually like a radio top 40 hit done
by an orchestra which is such
a unique element and i loved it yes
loved it
so the creator said this being a family
of eight children and there being eight
books
i would love to be able to focus and
really tell stories and love stories for
all the bridge or teen siblings
for each character for sure that i love
what the book is called yeah and that's
why this first one was all about daphne
because when i finished watching it i
was like what's the second season going
to be about like
it's kind of happily ever after but no
they're going to focus on the other
books the next book is called
the vi count who loved me and it's
focuses on anthony's journey
to find a wife right right right with
sienna and all the drama
yeah because at the end of the last
episode he was like i'm finding a wife
like love is
right right oh that's so interesting
okay so it's not going to follow
like their story is over like they're
happy good for them yeah i'm sure
they're going to be in the series and
obviously her being a duchess like will
influence things that happened with the
bridgerton's but like i love
i love this show already and i love this
journey for eight seasons like this
could just be
the next like thing that gets us like
for eight years right and
then it's like each of the kids by the
time it's like in the eighth season the
younger ones will be grown up
yeah and eligible for marriage oh that's
very interesting i think it's
such a great idea i really hope that it
gets the green light for eight seasons
because now we can talk about bridgerton
i loved it loved i mean so much to love
first of all
the scenery was just sickening the
scenery down like
a true utopia like gorgeous gorgeous
then
the music like the music was such a
premium content
level upper and the characters were just
wonderful like
like i just didn't know who to love the
most and loved the queen yeah and i also
loved how aside from daphne because we
saw her in younger
and these were all new faces so it just
like
made it just like a world of its own and
by the way i watch younger and couldn't
even recognize daphne from
being josh's i remember her now mama
yeah yeah the irish girl yeah yeah i
wonder if she'll go back to younger
i don't know she's a star now yeah she's
a big star um i just loved it like there
was just so many things about it that
were so premium and
really just like that's what that's
what's nice it's like it's kind of like
when you watch a shonda rhyme show or
like when you watch a ryan murphy show
you know there's a level of premiumness
that even if it's not your favorite show
it's still going to be really good
and it's going to be enjoyable so it has
the shonda land stamp of approval and i
just loved it
yeah there were like moments that were
frustrating just like for the story line
like obviously
the duke and um daphne
not like communicating and it's like she
like him just like
saying not wanting to have children not
that he couldn't have children i was
just like
it was just like frustrating for her
like well i intentionally misled her
right it was frustrating watching her
come to all these realizations but i'm
glad that eventually she did and i'm
also glad that she got the happy ending
yeah no it's like that never happens but
for the diamond of the season
she can find a love match and she ended
up she went from almost marrying
neugel to literally being in a love
match with the duke who like
nobody thought was even going to get
married and it was just so pretty and if
she wanted to she could have been a
princess
yeah no i did feel bad for the prince he
was a really nice boy he was a really
nice guy
and when i was watching it like before i
knew what happened and simon was just
kind of being a [ __ ] boy
and we didn't know that he was like otp
yeah and no
i knew that like she obviously had
feelings for him but he was not being
the man that she needed and like the
prince
is a prince and literally stepped up to
the plate like and i was just like i
want her to be with the prince
the princess of prussia like necessary
yeah it works for daphne 100
but the way that it all unfolded like
obviously i'm so happy with how it went
and now it's like prince who
yeah no and honestly not to be mean but
he was kind of ugly like that simon is
so much cuter
the sideburns oh our attitude
so glad you brought that
up especially on her older brother
those wolfy ass and i know that's the
style and they're just being accurate
with like the 1800s but my god it
bothered me so much it was so pubey like
so gross out of here i just have one
critique that i think is like a plot
hole
okay and that is that the second brother
who's like the artist
looks 20 years older than anthony he
looks like the dad i thought he was the
dad
like 100 i actually loved all the
brothers
in their own way anthony was kind of
annoying like a fuckboy but he'll get it
together
i thought the brother who like loves art
and like went to those parties like he
was just so sweet and innocent
and then the third brother who like
loved marina thompson and was friends
with penelope like he was pathetic and
so sweet
and just sweet no but such a decent guy
and that's what the whole thing was it's
like what i loved about the bridgertons
is like
in a time where like it felt like
everything was very cold like no
families were like warm and embracing
each other the bridgerton's were special
because they loved each other so much
and their family
and their father had passed away so like
the family was just so close and i just
like
loved the mom i thought she was like an
amazing matriarch and i just felt very
connected to the family and i
loved everything about them i totally
agree and i loved um
what's the girl with the bangs with the
half bangs yeah the sister eloise
eloise yeah and then the little ones the
campers they were so cute i can't wait
till we get to their love story
i know i mean it feels weird because
they're uh like six but
yeah it's very exciting i think it's a
great show i think it has great
potential for future seasons this
like the styling it was all very like
over the top 1800s but like gorgeous
yeah and i loved the queen and then her
backstory was like a little sad you know
yeah
but but interesting yeah i thought it
was excellent oh and then obviously
the fact that spoiler alert spoiler
alert spoilers
this is your warning you don't get
another one penelope uh featherington
was lady whistle down which i did not
see coming i really thought that they
had figured it out and it wasn't like a
mystery anymore
yeah but now it's like i love i'm like
so honored that they told us in the
first season who she is
yeah and didn't waste our time it's like
gossip girl and now it's like you could
even go back and watch it all again
and see how it is penelope all along and
i mean it makes total sense because
really the main like the smoking gun is
the fact that she knew about marina
thompson right
yes there were other people who knew i
thought maybe that um
penelope wrote in to lady featherington
and told her about marina
that's what i just assumed because she
like loved the bridgerton boy so much oh
that's so interesting and she wanted to
break them up
i mean justice for penelope i love her i
mean she's serving up justice for
herself and now it's like her family is
in ruin because
they're the mr featherington passed away
and there's no money in the pouch um
but penelope is trying to should be a
wealthy queen because she's the talk of
the tongue oh that's
so true she should be able to save her
family
and you know towards the end i really
did feel bad for the feathering tunes at
first like
excuse me they were like meant to be
made a mockery of but then i kind of
felt bad for them like the mom even
though she was annoying like
all she wanted was like for her kids to
be like famous and popular you know for
sure but like penelope being little lady
whistle down like gives them the credit
uh the upper hand like she can write any
narrative she could rewrite history yeah
um and honestly i just like the scenes
with marina thompson just made me so sad
because
she just couldn't catch a break and no
one was except for penelope looking out
for her
when her boyfriend's brother came i'm
like i thought it was him at first and
i'm like finally like this girl's gonna
get a break
yeah no his brother no one like she
turned him down because she thought she
was no longer with child and then it's
like
to shift to go back and ask him but i'm
glad i loved how her storyline ended
like she didn't seem so happy but in the
in the
in that world it could have been so much
worse it's the best case scenario
yeah and he was a nice boy and he was
gonna look after her and take care of
her
and back in the day they're gonna get
married yeah yeah okay i thought
yeah so yeah back in the day that's like
all you could ask for yeah so
it wasn't you know the bridgerton love
story we thought it was going to be but
it was it was fine
it wasn't the worst like lord rutledge
who's up the old man
oh god he was so scary yeah i just love
those balls and those galas and like i
just wanted to go to the opera you know
gotta get me a corset and a wig the hair
was crazy like the men's hair i mean
they were wearing those big wigs like
that was crazy
oh yeah crazy yeah no it was so good if
you guys are
haven't watched it or on the fence
definitely watch it yeah um
tv recap was that our fifth and final
that was our fifth and final yes
so let's talk a little bit about the
real housewives of atlanta which i have
some thoughts on because we haven't
watched in a few weeks
um and the real houses of atlanta recap
is brought to you by love book online
so valentine's day is coming up and if
you want to you know
get down with with someone that's that's
one option
but another option is to make them feel
warm and fuzzy on the inside with a love
book
love is in the air you guys valentine's
day is coming soon love book is a
personalized gift that helps people
express feelings that might be difficult
to say out loud most customers use a
love book to revisit their fondest
memories or to list the reasons why they
love someone
love books are completely customizable
though and people can use them however
they like
so um for valentine's day obviously your
partner or even like someone you love
like your mom like someone you're
thinking of
um someone would really appreciate like
a sentimental gift and something that
is just really descriptive of how much
they mean to you um you basically create
characters that look just like you and
the recipient
um and you can customize with all the
features that make you unique you can
even choose like hairstyles and outfits
um so you have the option to personalize
each page as much as much as you'd like
they also offer an express option where
you can create a complete book in just a
few minutes
love books are the perfect gift for any
occasion but especially for
anniversaries birthdays and of course
valentine's day
visit lovebookonline.comtoast to receive
a special 20 discount just for our
listeners
again that's lovebookonline.com
toast for a special 20 discount just for
the choose listeners valentine's day is
coming up and we're giving you enough
morning now so don't wait too long so
true i can't believe valentine's day is
coming up like does this is a great
warning time i can't wait for some
chocolate and a love book oh my god yum
i'll be off my cleanse hello
um okay real houses of atlanta was
actually so funny last night
um first of all i just have such a
hard time trusting kenya like i really
do but do you see
that like this season especially last
night's episode like she was just being
like so cute
no oh my god no i just it's so funny i
don't see it that way at all
because you want to know why when last
year when she almost ruined
intentionally and i remember coming on
this show and being like i
could not believe that like cynthia is
the only one who's been like ride or die
for kenya and she would go out of her
way to try and spoil her engagement like
that is not something a friend does that
is something a mean
girl does i was so hurt by it
and then i was like okay you know what
she actually recognizes how [ __ ] up it
was and she's trying to
better it but something about it felt
very insincere like first of all
why didn't she tell any of the other
women that it was a surprise party
especially when she knows that they're
notoriously late they would have come on
time
oh she didn't tell them no literally
portia showed up and she was like oh
it's an engagement party
oh that's true that's like poor planning
and it just makes me think she just like
wants the other women to look bad in
cynthia's eyes
oh that's a good point but cynthia has
really forgiven her and she's even a
bridesmaid
doesn't that mean that maybe you could
forgive her i just i forgive
i'm just so wary of her like every time
i start to like kenya she just does
something and i'm like no i knew it like
this is who you really are okay so what
she did
more hair care i will never forget that
was the meanest thing anyone's ever done
going into marlo thompson's hair event
last season
with a marching band to promote her own
hair care like
that's not what a friend does that is
not a hundred percent
so last night what did she do that upset
you so much
she's not telling the girls i'm just i'm
very wary
that's that's all i'm going to say okay
okay i have to say the party did look
kind of fun
it looked so funny like coveted friendly
phones friendly and
cynthia was so grateful you could really
tell in her confessionals when she was
just talking about like how
thankful she was that they put this on
for her and like it was
it was really sweet i do have to say
though like her and mike being like
disappointed when they showed up that it
wasn't like a
campaign joe biden thing was so funny
and honestly the
the surprise was kind of awkward no i
feel like that always happens with
surprises like what you tell the person
in order to get them to come is like
sometimes like
not better but also exciting yeah and
then you're like
wait but is that not happening yeah no
right right like where's joe biden like
that happened with your engagement too
when you were like wait are we not
meeting
with the shareholders yeah like it was
just so
um it was just so awkward especially
because no one was there it was like a
surprise party for four people at the
end
i love mike hill like i think chill
cynthia and him
are otp like i loved when everyone was
at the mic like improving i just want to
chill and obviously
candy was so good and like wrote a song
on the spot but i thought that kenya
was being hysterical no it was porsha oh
well kenya was on two but
when porsche was when they did it when
they do edit that porsche is
must be exhausted like literally from
putting the show on her back season
after season
she is the funniest one she's the most
interesting one i [ __ ] love she's my
bethany now she's my karen hugher like
i will defend till the death like i
[ __ ] love portia
she was being so funny and honestly yes
candy was singing really good
but it really made me cringe for like
every time i've ever like gotten on the
mic at a party and like thought i was
singing really good and like
how it honestly like is annoying and i'm
not gonna do that anymore when have you
done that really i do it all the time
like
get on the mic i look at weddings like
people are always just like throwing me
the mic and i'm just like singing and i
okay they throw it to you it's fine no i
just realize now it's like so cringy i'm
not why i thought
i thought it was like so fun last night
it was like improv karaoke
yes for everyone but like candy was
taking herself seriously which is like
what i do oh
no but i thought candy was like making
it legit yeah well she was but like i
said
because she's like a record-winning
right artist maybe it's just because
like i've been there but like i felt
embarrassed for any time i've ever done
that because like i got to see it
through a lens of like a regular person
yes speaking of candy her sending her
daughter to
college emotional when they started
playing the flashbacks
of all of her seasons on the show and
like when she was so little
it just shook me to my core i guess
candy is really the only og
left candy wasn't on season one oh i
guess yeah you're right you're right
you're right
so but she's been on the longest now
yeah
um and when they flash back and i forget
when she had such short hair
and riley was so small like it actually
is really crazy like
the the cycle of life you guys yeah also
them
maybe i was just hungry but them driving
to new york like in a sprinter van like
just eating
like just i was so that's like a crazy
rich way to go to college like a party
bus with a u-haul on the back
yeah but also because of covet otherwise
they would have flown oh right right
right
yeah honestly it just seems easier like
with your u-haul that just looked so fun
yeah candy's a good mom yeah oh my god
and when ace was like um
crying that he's not gonna be able to
clean for riley like that was really sad
i usually hate those scenes it's like
just send your college nobody cares but
i i totally agree i usually
hate those scenes but maybe because we
have over a decade worth of content
right
now i can yeah if you're a first season
wondering like
why no one cares that you're sending her
to college in your first season like
don't care or even third season and
you know i hate it the most on beverly
hills i feel like every season someone's
going to college and and by the way they
come home a semester later 100
so like no thank you or like brooke mark
brooks mark say never go back
[Laughter]
um but yeah i'm really happy for mike
and cynthia i actually think they're
like the perfect couple yeah and you
know like before
cynthia's wedding to peter like everyone
the audience her family had reservations
and i feel like nobody feels that way
about mike like they're such a good
couple yeah it's good stuff
it was a great episode oh and kenya and
latoya's friendship like is weird
oh my god so weird but latoya's showing
the nude photo like
at the table in front of other people's
like husbands was so inappropriate i
don't know what she was getting at no
that's like when lala took her shirt off
in front of everyone's boyfriends and
vanderpump rules
yeah well that was worse but no i i
don't know for some reason this just
like really struck me because it's not
your picture to show first of all
yeah and also making it your phone
background like let's just talk like
that's a weird thing for you to do like
as a person no the whole thing
it wasn't didn't seem weird to me when
they were shopping for lingerie maybe
just like
showing uh but like to show it to a
whole table and it's not even your photo
i was just like and kenya seemed fine
with it but i just would not have been
fine with it no i agree that was just
like a weird
um their friendship is weird yeah also
drew wasn't in the episode
because her father-in-law passed away um
but i didn't even realize he wasn't
there yeah
she's i just don't know anything about
her yet like she's too fresh yeah and
now she missed an important episode
she did yeah um just justice for porsha
and
i absolutely oh and i have to say you
know who's a true hero of the franchise
obviously marlo i love her but lauren
portia sister she's like been so
consistent like she's always on the show
she's such a good sister like
they're so supportive they have such a
good relationship and i didn't even
realize until this week that
um they don't have the same mom i always
thought that porsha's mom was lauren's
mom
yeah but she's not and i just love to
learn learning about their background
and i will be purchasing
that was my portion you'll be purchasing
the book no it was she did a really good
commercial for it
it was excellent um so yeah tonight we
have the bachelor with matt james and
bachelor
i'm so excited yeah no it's actually
really good and it's fun to recap like
it is and you know what's like the
cleanse has really put me on a whole new
schedule and i've been going to sleep
really early
i think i can stay up till 10 to finish
the bachelor though but it's really
crazy like i really knew your new me
yeah um just i'm waking up earlier
because i need to leave time to like
make my smoothies
and so and i also like get kind of
hungry at night or just like bored and
wanting yeah so i'm just like okay i
should go to sleep
and so it's really just like put me on a
new schedule and plus like having bruno
sweets like i'm a morning person now
like i
like both days this weekend i woke up at
nine like on my own wow that's so
annoying i woke up
wake up at two yeah okay 12 30 was so
delicious
me and men were until four watching lost
like no but it's like if i wake up
whatever time i wake up on my own as
long as it's on my own i don't mind what
time it is
i feel the same if i wake up on my own
like with no alarm at 7 30 or 12 30
the fact that i woke up on my own
volition i have the free will to wake up
whenever i want
makes me not tired a hundred percent but
i could set an alarm for 11 and i'm
[ __ ]
exhausted something about the alarm is
like
ruins your life yeah i actually think
that like what we're saying is also
backed by science just like your rem
cycle like sometimes your alarm to start
disrupts your rem cycle so even if it's
later
you might be in like a lighter sleep at
7 30. my rem cycle was 100 disturbed
this morning like no doubt about it you
know what i woke up naturally and then
my alarm went off but that's also
because zach set his alarm earlier
which he always does um so yes bachelor
tonight and then tons of recaps all week
and just wonderful episodes for you all
week so thank you so much for being here
thank you so much
for listening to the morning toast the
millennium morning show where we deliver
the past five stories that you need to
know
every monday through friday on youtube
so if you're watching us on youtube
please feel free to subscribe and give
this video a thumbs up
we're also available as a podcast
anywhere podcast can be found spotify
itunes stitcher public radio i have
radio cast box
all the places so wherever you listen to
podcasts find us morning toast subscribe
and leave a five star review about how
beautiful stunning and smart we are hope
you have an amazing day you guys don't
let the monday blues get you down
we'll see you back here for tomorrow's
show bye-bye